le désir de paix de l'occident et il ya
eu problème des jihadistes ça c'est la
grosse question je pense surtout qu'ils
y voient une opportunité une opportunité
de vaincre c'est vrai qu'ils sont très
conscients je pense du fait qu' ils
acceptent eux la guerre comme une
nécessité
ou comme une norme de la vie humaine qu
en outre il y a une forme de guerre
en l'occurrence le jeu c'est à dire la
guerre sainte qui est consacré par la
religion alors qu'eux ils ont claire
conscience que l'occident a de plus en
plus de mal à faire la guerre et en ce
sens il y voit un avantage tout
simplement dans la guerre qu'ils peuvent
mener contre l'occident avec vire je ne
pense pas que ça les gêne beaucoup que
l'occident soit pacifique que je pense
au contraire il y voit une des formes du
déclin de l'occident de son incapacité à
mener le monde comme il l'a fait pendant
un ou deux siècles
on
au monde